[موسيقى]
بالنسبه الى افغانستان حدث ذلك عقب احداث
الحادي عشر من سبتمبر في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه حيث كانت القاعده تتخذ من
افغانستان لها وبما انه تم استهداف
الولايات المتحده مباشره من خلال احداث
الحادي عشر من سبتمبر والمشاهد التي
شهدناها ولا سيما من انهيار البرجين في
نيويورك وعليها ان تدخل فرنسا
في الحرب العالميه الثانيه لذلك تدخلنا في
افغانستان
[موسيقى]
اما بالنسبه الى العراق فالوضع مختلف
غير مقبوله بالنسبه الينا
طرفه لكنها ذات مخزن في مطلع الفتره التي
تسلم فيها وزاره الدفاع التقينا في اجتماع
فبراج او وارسو لم اعد اذكر بالضبط اين مع
دونالدز فيلد الذي كان نظير الامريكي الذي
اراد وقتها ان يقنع الاوروبيين بالمشاركه
في العمليه المنوي تنفيذها في العراق
بواسطه الاقمار الصناعيه وعرضها علينا حيث
لم يكن هناك الا وزراء حول الطاوله وقدمت
تلك الصور على انها من الصوت لاطلاق
الصواريخ وقال ان صدام حسين سيستخدم هذه
المنصات لاطلاق الصواريخ عندما عرض رمز في
صوره اخرجت الصور التي التق الاقمار
الصناعيه الفرنسيه التي اظهرت انها تتعلق
بصوامع القمح فقط الزاويه التي تم من
خلالها التقاط الصور لم تكن نفسها الصور
التي اظهرها الامريكيون واعتقد كان لديهم
غيرها كان بالامكان ان تظهر وكانها من
الصوت لاطلاق الصواريخ وصور التي لدينا
والماخوذه من زاويه اخرى اظهرت انها تتعلق
بمنشاه مدنيه
[موسيقى]